hey guys it's Alicia Malone welcome to
another Fandango in the movie guide
let's get straight into it with a giant
peak movie that caused a whole lot of
havoc in kanne oak Joe is directed by
bong joon-ho who also did the host and
Snow piercer this is his sixth feature
film and just like those movies he looks
at a slightly unrealistic world to talk
about real issues actually happening
this beautiful and special little
creature revolution in the livestock
industry this is like a dark children's
film like a bleaker version of ET where
a young girl Mita
falls in love with a giant pig called
okhta who's been sent to her farm in
Korea in order to grow fat and then
eventually be turned into food they will
also leave a minimal footprint on the
environment and most importantly they
need to taste good archers jam-packed
with a lot of ideas vegetarianism the
food industry capitalism corporate greed
and it fears between comedy action and
then drama that might make you never
want to eat meat again ten years in
planning on the cusp of the products
that will feed millions what happens
that farmer girl who's gonna destroy us
I applaud Netflix for funding this kind
of movie because this is the type of
film that would rarely get made in the
studio today but that can caused a lot
of controversy when it was included in
the competition that was because Netflix
at the time had no plans to distribute
the film in French theatres so there was
a lot of hoo-ha which resulted in the
audience's booing the Netflix logo this
film will be released in limited
theaters but thank God for Netflix for
getting out this original movie around
the world not a perfect film some of the
tonal shifts don't quite work but
overall it is highly unique very
entertaining and has a lot to say
[Music]
now to some naughty nuns in the little
hours this focuses on 13th century many
evil nuns who all speak like this
beautiful morning sister it's so absurd
it almost feels like a spoof movie and
it's got a fantastic cast with Alison
Brie Aubrey Plaza and Kate Micucci
playing these nuns who start to go a
little bit crazy when a hunky gardener
who they're told is a deaf-mute comes to
work at their farm played by dave franco
it's by writer director jeff vienna and
it's a twist on the Decameron but mixed
with a whole lot of improv comedy
juniors know you're nice there's a lot
of crazy physical comedy and a fantastic
supporting cast it starts to go a little
bit off the rails as it heads towards
the end and some of the jokes may wear
on you a little bit but overall the
little hours is fresh and fun and oh so
silly language
eating blood do you think I've ever
written down an eating blood before
bling-bling for my own thing and last
but not least I wanted to mention that
t2 Trainspotting is now available to buy
on Fandango now choose life choose
Facebook Twitter Instagram and hope that
someone somewhere cares miss Chiba
I missed you too spicy this is one of my
favorite films from 2017 it's so hard to
do a follow up to a really beloved film
that came out back in the 90s but
because Danny Boyle is in the front feet
once again and all the cast are back
together
it ends up being like this nice
nostalgic reunion with your beloved drug
addicts and also pushes the story
forward with a new adventure choose
reality TV standing at the gates of the
rich looking in at the Lamborghinis
chooses either our contract a two-hour
journey to work and choose the safety of
kids only worse and I am just in awe of
Danny Boyle's visual style this is the
director who continues to push himself
and really new and interesting ways it's
so fun to see all the cars back together
again and especially Ewan McGregor
leading the charge so choose life choose
t2 Trainspotting on Fandango now choose
the ones you love choose your future
choose life
so a quick wrap-up the perfect film to
watch on Netflix this weekend is okhta
you can go out to limited theaters and
catch the little hours or you can also
stay at home with Fandango now and watch
t2 Trainspotting as always let me know
what you've been watching in the
comments below or on twitter at alicia
Malone and I'll see you soon
[Music]